so people are like coming up to me and
saying yeah i love all your videos and
everything you're saying is great and
it's practical it's not genius but it's
practical and you're showing us how to
do it and we appreciate that
but there's a big problem i'm not as
charismatic
or you know over the top or handsome
as you are you know so what do i do and
i wanted to finally break something down
when did being completely over the top
and full of en energy and just massively
explosive
become so awesome because a lot of
people email me and tell me how awesome
it is and
how they wish they were like that but
i've got to be honest with you if you're
an introvert instead of an extrovert
you could be doing the same things i'm
doing you've just got to crush them with
content guys do you think it's a lot of
fun to be the way i am
let me tell you something i'm just
embracing who i am and i'm accepting who
i am
and that's what's so important you've
got to really just love your own dna
you are you and if you've got good
content and you know what you're talking
about whatever the subject matter is
you'll be respected as long as you
hustle and keep putting it out there see
the funny thing is
guys is that there are plenty of people
plenty of people and you know them
behind the scenes
it's great that oh i have all this
popularity a lot of people say nice
things it's because i really do care and
i do pump out stuff and i think that
it's got some value and i really really
do care and people feel it
because i email everybody back and i
direct message people but
there are plenty of people that think
i'm a jerk off
that think i'm a douchebag that think
i'm way high energy or full of [ __ ]
there's people out there that think that
and what i've noticed over the last two
three years is that
over time not that i've won them over
but that i've continued to pump out good
content
i continue to you know put my uh my
work where my mouth is or what is it you
know you know i just continue to answer
my email i continue to work hard i
continue to build brand equity
i continue to also give and do 15 minute
phone calls with people that just
randomly ask for it
and i think when you do the right things
when your actions speak louder than your
words
even if your words are completely
obnoxious and over the top like some
people think
i am or very slow and somber and
articulate
and direct like maybe you are it's all
about the content at the end of the day
and sure i could be a showman and all
that
and that's just my natural dna but if
you don't think i realized that if i
just toned it down a hair
just a hair that i would be more
accepted there's
plenty of people that hate my style as a
matter of fact
there's a lot of people that hate that
over the topness and it's too much
and everybody thinks i'm on crack or red
bull i get it
and i respect it and i think people need
to understand that you need to respect
other people's opinion you need to be
truthful with yourself i'm telling you
if i was seven percent less over the top
i'd be ten times
bigger if you understand where i'm going
with that but i can't be seven percent
less
i've got to be me and the quicker you're
you and realize
it's not the personality but it's the
content and the hard work
and seeing opportunity and networking
and however you do it
that really separates you from the pack
i can yell and scream and be all crazy
and do all this but unless i back it up
unless there's true results unless
people go out there and
use me for consulting and then do things
and it actually works unless all those
things happen
you lose so it's about the chops do you
have the chops
if you do it doesn't matter if you yell
or if you whisper